みなさん今日はね
と～っても可愛い友達を連れてきたの！
ボンッ　ボンボンッ…
今日連れて来た友達はこの二人
メルちゃんです(*‘ω‘ *)
ん～　可愛いね♡
こっちのショートヘアのほうは普通のメルちゃんです
ショートヘアの可愛い女の子
おせわだいすきメルちゃん
お風呂に入れると髪の毛が
ピンク色になったりしますね
あぁ～可愛い～
今日はもう一人買った女の子がいるんだ
それはこちら！
髪の毛の長い女の子だねぇ
この子はメルちゃんのサラサラロングのお友達
メルちゃんのお友達だね
可愛いね♡
この子には名前がないから
僕が名前をつけてあげるんだ
というわけでこのロングヘアの女の子の名前はねぇ
ん～どうしようかな
この女の子の名前は”轟(とどろき)ちゃん”
ん～　可愛い名前だね(*^^*)
真顔
じゃあ早速開けてみよう
まずは主役のメルちゃんですよ
じゃあ早速開けてみましょう
メルちゃん可愛いねぇ
早く開けてみたいよぅ
お”お”
お”お”っしゃぁあ
できた！
今日から僕のお友達のメルちゃんだよ
みんな仲良くしてねぇ！
もう一人お友達を連れてきましょう
僕はなんかそういうロリコンとかじゃないんですけど
どっちかというとこういう髪型の女の子のほうがね
好きなんだよね
ごめんねメルちゃん！
（死ね！はじめん！）
じゃあお友達のほうも開けていきましょう
あぁこっちのほうが俺は好みだわ
どっちかと言われると俺はこっちのほうが好きだなぁ
あ、ロリコンじゃないよ
ロリコンじゃないけどこうなんか女の子の髪型
とかっていうとこういう女の子がタイプですね
できた！でたでた！
よぉし！できたぞ！
轟ちゃんですね
この子がメルちゃんのお友達の
轟ちゃんです！
コイツの方は...あ、違った
轟ちゃんには～
くしとゴムバンドがついてたね
（はじめん、ロリへの第一歩）
ンフッフ
ほんとに可愛いなぁ
というわけで今日はね
この女の子二人と
遊んでみようと思います！
うわぁぁぁあぁああぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁああぁぁ
88888888888888888👏
ボンッ
ボトッ
トン
パラパラ
というわけで今日はですね
ボンッ
このメルちゃんと
轟）ボンッ
轟ちゃんでね
タイマン対決をしてもらおうと思います
轟）ボンッ
俺はねずっと疑問に思ってたんですよ
こいつらのどっちが本当に強いかというのを
俺ははっきりさえたいと思ってる
だから今日は
この二人にタイマンをさせてもらおうと思います
轟）ボンッ
僕的には～
僕的にはもう完全に
このメルちゃんのお友達の方が
ちょっとまぁ好きなんで 好みの問題ですけどね
ビジュアル的には、こっちのメルちゃんのお友達のほうが好きなんで
僕はこっちをちょっと応援しようと思います
どっちが強いかっていうのを
今日は検証してみようと思います
楽しみだね♡
ドンッ
実況）赤コーナーより入場しますは〜
天下一品の大化け物
お世話大好きメルちゃんです！
漆黒のワンピースに包まれたそのボディ
魅惑の山肌
３６度以上のお湯につかると
髪の毛がピンク色に変化
まさにメタモルフォーゼでございます
両手から伸びるその人差し指に
なにを繰り出すのか！
特技の超能力
サイコパスで相手を地獄に
導けるのか？
テクニカルな戦いが楽しみでございます
続いて青コーナーから入場するは
メルちゃんのお友達、サラサラロングのお友達
轟ちゃんでぇ～す
サラサラの髪の毛超キューティクルでございます
ロングヘア―好きのはじめんにはたまりません
おっとロリコンじゃないですよ
本来はメルちゃんと仲良さそうですが実は犬猿の仲
今回のタイマンバトルで
決着をつけたいようでございます
さぁ主役の座は奪い取れるのか
轟ちゃん出陣です！
どっちが勝つか全く分かりませんね
まっ、僕はね、奥の髪の毛長いメルちゃんのお友達推しなんですけどね
さ、では戦いを見守りましょう
可愛い戦い楽しみですね
３！２！１！スタート~♪
さぁどっちが勝つかなぁ～
どっちが勝つかわかんねぇぞ～
さぁどっちが勝つか？！
ん～わかんない
さあどっちが勝つか！？
どっちが勝つかな？
轟）ボンッボッ
（目の前で起きた光景が信じられないはじめん）
ニコッ
真顔